the State Department oversees our
Foreign Relations national security and
assists Americans abroad it was created
way back in 1789 and witch's old and our
president likes things to be young new
and lean so he's trimming the fat
Trump is pledged to cut nearly a third
of the department's budget because the
president knows what's most important
let me tell you the one that matters is
me I'm the only one that matters because
when it comes to if that's what the
policy is going to be with Trump
handling international diplomacy all
alone many career Foreign Service
officers have left or been pushed out
and of the 152 key positions he should
appoint more than half are unfilled but
with Trump's tweets who needs them there
are 41 embassies without confirmed
ambassadors and that's even in places
where there are crises no ambassador in
South Korea Saudi Arabia in Turkey
our foreign policy objectives continue
to be met he's right
so I'm facing off with six diplomats
who've left under this administration to
let them know we're doing just fine
without them they may have a hundred
fifty years of combined experience all
over the world but what are they ever
done to make America great I help bring
home the only servicemen being held by
the enemy in Afghanistan I helped
coordinate the evacuation of 15,000
Americans helped to bring 1,000 children
out of Haiti immediately after the
earthquake it feels a little bit like
bragging I'll just kick things off with
the softball the State Department for
International Department what was your
favorite country to serve it very hard
to say
Malta Egypt I would actually say Iraq
Czechoslovakia Yugoslavia I see why you
guys aren't working at the State
Department because the correct answer
was America it's the best country that
you forgot it a second ago I don't know
much about the State Department except I
know that it's fat its bloated if in the
space of one year one third of all the
generals and admirals in the military
chose to retire because of a new
president there would be an uproar well
that's not happening because we're
adding billions to our military budget
if we do our job right then the military
doesn't have to do it
talking and listening to other countries
this sends like um marriage counseling
and they know it doesn't work
I showed up once to that and I walked
right out and guess what my marriage
still broke up I think people who were
most successful in business find that
talking and listening making your case I
don't wanna do this what war was ever
ended with diplomacy can you name me one
sure Bosnia Kosovo these are areas that
I worked on don't don't try to overly
sell yourself maybe talking worked in
the 90s but America no longer needs
face-to-face contact to get its point
across more and more we are literally
absent from discussions dealing with the
most urgent crisis that we have with
North Korea right now and we have no
ambassador in South Korea moment yeah
we've never been less respected around
the world than we are today
we're worried about our popularity
overseas that's an easy fix I don't give
I care about credibility and that's what
we're losing daily you vote for the S
word around like that I don't know if
you'll find this reassuring but the risk
of nuclear war in the last year has
risen to remote but very conceivable
cool so the bunker that I invested in
was a decent idea I'm not worried about
North Korea's nuke because Trump's
handling world affairs in the most
modern way possible this is what
diplomacy looks like why would Kim Jang
hoon insult me by calling me old when I
would never call him short and bat oh
well I try so hard to be his friend and
maybe someday that will happen take this
hot fire Twitter diplomacy and revert it
into old-school diplomacy this is easy
it's easy we've got to lower the
temperature in our public comments if we
sit down and talk and we'll find out we
have more common interests than we think
Jesus that's boring how about this one
I've told Rex Tillerson our wonderful
Secretary of State your guy's ex boss
that he is wasting his time trying to
negotiate with little rocket man the
message I would I would convey is our
patience with diplomacy is
coming to an end you didn't use any
nicknames at all Posada did you leave
that out how much time on average does
somebody works for the State Department
spend brainstorming nicknames for
leaders of other countries zero hours so
you know you don't have a quick go-to
for Angela Merkel leader of the free
world Merkel you go you go
German Hillary these guys might be
useless to trump but maybe I can help
them land a job because I'm starting a
new domestic affairs office that I'm
calling the United States Department to
get your resumes here and we are looking
for a general ambassador of flyover
country
we're definitely definitely looking for
an Undersecretary of the forgotten man
that office will be located in a bar in
Wisconsin
Shri all right here it looks like resume
says an expert on Russian propaganda
combating Russian propaganda thank you
though yeah if you know there's some use
for that few days yeah Megan okay I
spent time in Slovenia I know there are
number one export in Slovenia is models
I don't know if that's number one I've
done a little bit of research what I
know about Lavinia is models come here
and they become first lady it's it's an
amazing trajectory if you really look at
it this undersecretary the forgotten man
so the position any of you might guess
that the Wisconsin bar discuss tempting
yeah yeah sign me up I'll put you that
well it's not a signup situation to be
an interview process but it's an honor
just to be nominated great but I would
say Jordan and I think I speak for
everyone you know we spend most of our
careers overseas working with non
Americans but we all feel
extraordinarily grateful for having had
the opportunity we had and so we don't
get to say to Americans very often but
thank you thank you yeah you're welcome
nice right kiss up thank God we no
longer have these people
beam us overseas
[Applause]
[Music]